(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This is the eastern
Ukrainian City of Bakhmut
in summer 2022,
and this is what it looked
like half a year later.
Moscow has been trying to
take Bakhmut since last July,
turning it into the sight
of the bloodiest fight
of Russia's war in Ukraine.
While some military analysts
and Western officials
have debated how important the city is
to the overall conflict,
both Moscow and Kyiv
have doubled down on
their military operations.
(Sergei speaking Russian)
(Volodymyr speaking Ukrainian)
- [Narrator] Here's how Bakhmut turned
into a political symbol
for Kyiv and Moscow
and why this battle has been
so difficult for both sides.
(upbeat music)
Located in the highly
contested Donetsk region,
Bakhmut wasn't an obvious spot on the map
to become one of the
focal points of the war.
The city does sit on a
number of major roads,
linking it to strategically
important locations
in the region.
But Bakhmut itself isn't a
significant transportation hub
according to some military analysts,
and the city's hilly terrain
makes it a difficult place
to advance from.
- If the Russians do
eventually take Bakhmut,
they'll have to go over higher ground
and the Ukrainians have had plenty of time
to build highly defensible
positions there.
- [Narrator] Some of those positions
are in the town of Chasiv Yar
that sits on a hill around six miles west
where Ukrainians have
been digging trenches.
More can be found further west
in Kramatorsk and Slovyansk,
the heavily fortified Ukrainian
strongholds in Donetsk.
- [Stephen] It's not gonna be easy
for the Russians from now on
even if they take the the city.
- [Narrator] This makes it
unlikely that taking control
of the city would be a
turning point for Russia.
So why have both sides
continued to fight for the city?
Ukrainian commanders say they aim
to exhaust Russian forces
there and give themselves time
to prepare for offensives of their own,
and for Russia, the battle has turned
into a defining moment for Wagner,
the mercenary group that
spearheaded the Russian offensive.
Thanks to them, the region
surrounding the city
is one of the few places
where Moscow has made any major
progress since last summer.
But to do this,
the group has invested almost
its entire supply of recruits,
sending waves of soldiers
to near certain death.
In March, a UK military advisor estimated
that between 20,000 and
30,000 Russian troops
have been killed or wounded
in the area around Bakhmut
since the start of the offensive.
- Bakhmut has developed a
symbolic significance far greater
than the operational or strategic
significance of the city.
- [Narrator] And military
analysts say Ukraine's losses,
which are classified, are also increasing.
Russian and Ukrainian military
officials didn't respond
to our request for comment
on the number of casualties
they've suffered in Bakhmut.
(upbeat music)
Ukrainian president, Volodymyr Zelensky,
has come under criticism at home
for deciding to defend Fortress
Bakhmut as he called it,
despite mounting deaths.
But in late March, Western officials
and some military analysts
said Russia's offensive
in Bakhmut was losing momentum.
- It may be that the Russians
have effectively exhausted themselves
or it may be that the
Russians are just pausing,
hoping to resupply and go at
it again with one final push.
- [Narrator] Despite questions about
the city's strategic importance,
the large number of troops and ammunition
that both sides have
poured into the battle
has created a military
significance of its own.
- The next thing really to watch
will be what happens when
Ukrainian forces re-equipped
with Western tanks and other
sophisticated equipment
and try to take back more
land occupied by the Russians.